hello everyone and yeah I should
actually get my microphone when I say
that so there we go I got my Serena
already in the chat which is which is
pretty awesome and even knows who you
are
see he says hello Valentina and Musa
Dagh hello Musa Dagh
yeah today today the guest is smash
hello to the today the guest is my
sister who is not a very strong chess
player but she is a very eager to learn
and she's super bored today so that so
she's keeping us keeping us busy Hey set
up Luke
welcome to the excellent subscribers
chronal Dina also here a lot of people
joining in very quickly Tina Tina how
are you doing thank you how are you how
are you enjoying the stream so far very
a lot of people already joining in and
basically this is what we do so we have
two tournaments unfortunately we didn't
manage to cover the first one because
the first one was from 7 to 8 and Carson
and Geary were taking their stream a bit
too long their match and we only got to
the second tournament but we are going
to show I also lost in the first game
too bad for your sorrows but we are
going to show the winners of the meadow
arena Mehta has the the first tournament
it's the Midori Knights only for players
who are rated lower than 17-hundred and
here we have hand sanitizer won the
tournament
followed by team market followed by TJ's
law then buck Robert smog smog released
oh one two
cacoa Niner 9660 clan four four four
four one Oryx and meadow means fear
Brazil yes it does yes it does in the
meadow 1700 so those are the top ten
congratulations guys sorry I didn't
managed to enter the stream sooner but
Carson and Geary have to take it all the
way six full games but we are going to
cover more of that tomorrow
all right Valentina Valentina is my
sister as the title of the stream
suggests and now alright we are going to
check out one game by the leader now so
this is like a stream where we don't
usually play like we can play a few
games like maybe after three maybe in
between in between tournaments but
mostly it's for my subscribers they play
and then I randomly pick games and then
we enjoyed their games so it's it's a
lot of fun and you might get your game
shown on on the channel so that makes it
all the more exciting but at your
Shaymin yeah we will not be talking
about who won as maybe you know not a
lot of people have seen that yes the the
title is a pretty big giveaway Valentina
is the sister yes well well spotted
what's her rating do you know what
what's your rating in chess 3000 is well
said yeah that's like the absolute top
no one is rated that much all the chairs
hey man good to see you on this stream
as well we had some good good premium
Zelda action funny in the morning on
Twitch good you're awake the entire day
how is she your sister she's beautiful
thank you I mean thank you I think
that's that I think that's only a
compliment for you I think that's that's
that wasn't a compliment for me
[Laughter]
yeah and Tarun thanks for joining us
Maris ah thank you thank you
that is that is very very good to hear
okay so here we have taken on gazzarri
I'm from Armenia our frequent player
against TQ pain and you see this little
icon here yeah that means that this
player berserk and berserk King means
that they each have three minutes when
they start but if you berserk then you
only have a minute and a half it cuts
your time in half but you get more
points if you win so it's like bragging
or showing off like you say I only need
half of my time to beat you and I also
will get more points so this guy did
that and he hopes to be that guy since
you see he's much higher rate at his
2440 and he's 1867 no not not $3,000 all
right yeah no matter is actually also
here yeah she's right she's right the
middle is right behind Tina no not not
that way yeah but no Mather is always
behind so it's not another problem no we
didn't manage the stream meadow arena
Posthumus Eze I love you 3000 so Iron
Man Iron Man reference all right who is
older guess guess guess who is older all
right
Oh Filipino is also here let's check out
his game and then we're gonna go as we
say deeper into the rabbit hole sister
by wedding or sister sister sister
what's a sister by wedding oh yeah
sister-in-law yeah I yell and ice
playing in the tournament she's in she's
in the room upstairs Valentina is older
ah see everyone everyone thinks so yeah
I still don't know okay Cuomo says
Valentina is 22 oh thanks yeah of course
they they're saying you're older send
some very very immature and the juvenile
how are we getting getting so so many
rates from from with it did not give us
some juicy stories as a kid yes please
do please I am here you have to ask
specific questions yeah yeah if you have
any any specifics she's all ears
ah yeah but I got this sixteen so he has
to be like 24 yeah at least at least I'm
interested how do you how do you do
raids on YouTube I I mean I know on
Twitch doors like raid button but how do
you do a raid on YouTube I've never knew
that post who says did I pee my pants
[Music]
yeah I mean even if I did I I mean I
wouldn't show anyone yeah that'd be
that'd be pretty weird
I you request the viewers to raid ah
okay so it's not a not an automatic
click okay and of course yeah I always
forgot to mention the to mention this
you joined the arena by clicking on the
link in the description below it says
Friday arena and then the link and then
you just played and if you've played at
least 20 games and leeches that will be
sufficient Filipino that's Philly to
Warren's son he's playing against the
d-mat and no no one berserk so it's
gonna be interesting he always loses
whenever I show his game for some reason
okay
and now now he's gonna win see now he's
gonna capture this pawn with the king
and now he kicks away the rook and now
the rook moves and that's it
and he resigns there you see minus six
plus five very nicely done
good game good game Filipino all right
let's see who do we have here in the top
all right Jelena are you having a good
game all right
all right we have permission to show
yelling has game ah ah B's also playing
very nice that's what I like to see all
right let's see Jelena is playing
against me one forever
Mulan forever where you can scroll up ha
biggest sibling argument you've ever had
but that's not like a one argument
that's an argument that frequent
arranged like for 10 years is the next
podcast guest known and when will be
there yes the next podcast guest is
known but I will still not disclose the
identity of this mystery person but you
are welcome to try and guess
do you know who is the mystery person
yes really
yeah how do you know okay or maybe I
maybe I mentioned it when I was having a
beer or five I don't know
ha how do you joined elite chess arena
just click on the link in the
description below and join in tarun asks
when the manga is being released very
very soon what was Antonius most silly
haircut when he was younger
well the the spikes like that yeah like
a punk hairdo yeah everything was
shaving
yeah I don't know what's the name for
that never spikey yeah why don't I know
the name mohawk yeah mohawk of course so
weird I couldn't remember that all right
that was a that was a good one let's see
all right another rank is someone who
you will know very very soon although
you don't know who he is just yet his
identity will be revealed like maybe in
a week or two but he's he's a very
important person just just saying that
do you know why do you look like a
politician does she look like a corrupt
politician or like like a normal one
let's say from Finland or something like
that do you know what it means
yes but I can tell really you know
syringae together yeah very interesting
I don't think I had the nickname back
then I buddy I did yeah I did yeah I did
maybe a part of it someone says you look
like a communist
it looks like Colleen does daughter all
right let's see Knight captures nicely
nicely forking the two rooks and the
Queen so a nice Royal Fork
see when a knight attacks like the two
rooks or if the knight attacks like two
royal pieces then it's a it's a fork and
if it's like a Queen and the rook then
we sometimes call it a Royal fork and
that's very very very nasty yeah
but it's still very early in the
tournament and it's it will last for an
hour and a half so a lot more action to
be had I got helium Voice on yeah I
don't know why I ever since I did the
stream in the morning I was it was sort
of like a helium Voice what do I know
about Finland not much but I do hear
their politicians are not corrupt yeah
because they are mostly women oh yeah
stock was just crushed updated what
stock fish just crushed updated Okimoto
with the white pieces yeah okay but
isn't the TCC finished it aren't they
already in the super finals India's
politicians are very corrupt yeah okay
I imagine most countries politicians are
Nandi asks Tina do you play chess when
was the last game you played with you 10
years ago wow that's that's a lot of
years yeah pretty sure I lost I lost
once 10 years ago and she never wanted
to play again all right Abby Abby no
I'll be lost but good game good game
all right let's go deeper into the
rabbit hole let's see
Travie let's see okay let's check for a
game we want to show a game that is just
starting out so we can see much much
more Craig Craig K 84 thanks for the
contribution man says have a trot it's
on us will do maybe maybe it's gonna be
more like slivovitz abut yeah yeah
nickname
yeah pretty sure was yeah this is what
name do you keep of your daughter what I
think I think they mean to ask what what
name do you give the daughter because we
had the video when everyone was
suggesting names for for your daughter
no they were suggesting names for my son
I for your son yes okay I mixed it up as
well daughter is Santi Santi is an
Indian name and boy is Adam yeah is
Santi an Indian name I think our our
Indian friends will be able to crack
this one Frank true slow thank you for
the contribution man yes we are having
both actually I'm having some wine and
Tina's having a beer ah
they say it's Shanti so it's sort of an
sort of an Indian it means peace but
does Santi is something anything that's
a pretty big change to change what no no
I mean I read somewhere that Santi meant
like a peace of mind
uh-huh not just peace of mind some
Indian goddess who's named Sun tea or
maybe shun okay ah
they say Santi has no meaning no okay
too bad
ah okay so I guess it is only Shanti
yeah they say something is used in Italy
yes it is also in creation but we had to
change it a little bit yeah fantasy will
be will be strong here
they say it's Lord Rama's sister do we
have it you can learn everything here
yeah
come to come to India after Corona I
think India the the corona is still
pretty pretty strong in India it's still
full lockdown and it's still not even
hasn't even peaked and I really
shouldn't say that name on streams they
might take it take it down again so
everybody saying that we are not brother
and sister because we have a different
hair color okay but yeah they don't know
that I I dyed my hair yeah it was
actually much much lighter but I didn't
go well with with the camera so I
thought yeah let's let's just switch it
all right so X are the winds and takes
down a much higher rated Brutus who
berserk
so he was a very long time but okay
let's let's grab another game do you see
any nickname you like okay we're gonna
check out cod roe but now he already
kids already played a lot of moves the
what ah beyond a alright
could be or something with beyond I
think that's let me just show you that
okay
I've got to try red hair we'll think
about it
ah okay guess who that was and yeah it
was it wasn't the mailman but it kind of
was he did deliver something yeah Tina
who is who is better at chess
Magnus or Kasparov what do you think
Fisher Fisher okay that's that's a good
answer
ah he someone asked why the dog didn't
bark well that is strange
the the person who arrived at the door
was bringing something meadow meadow
enjoys so he did he didn't bark at it
okay he standard
thanks for the contribution man make it
a make it a Vishnu instead well we will
make it something we will make it
something all right so here a nice fork
to end the game and beyond the losses
your your your champion lost Tina all
right palanquin
all right he's already played a lot
against I'm trying to pick some games we
haven't seen before some names not games
all right let's see a dynamic rookie
versus Choquette and rocket berserks all
right mode rich or icky teach Tina
Tina lost by trial by combat I never
have to try very hard since I I have no
idea I don't follow football at all hey
Paco greetings greetings all the way
from Mexico no we are not Russian not
even close
yeah but we do get mistaken a lot yeah
in other countries all right let's see
what's happening here
your Zorro is married to a good sister
no he's not no no no he's not no yeah
you've missed it up close but but not
exactly does Antonio talk about
different things in family meetings
instead of chess
he never talks about chess yeah because
no one's interested yeah that's kind of
kind of why I started the channel all
right dynamic rookie doing very well on
time and on the board
he's down upon but I don't think he
minds and how is that night all right he
doesn't care he goes after the b7 pawn
and see he's very long time only 47
seconds but he has one extra pawn but
it's a doubled pawn so I don't think
he'll be able to make it because it's
all Wow
white just white just gave up a piece
for no apparent reason but still he is
much better on time so I think it will
be it will be fine Kaushik yeah I'm
doing well man I'm doing well how are
you yeah yeah the knight was trapped I
just didn't know why he why he got it
all the way up there to d6
no I'm not a chess player unfortunately
yeah yeah be someday are you going to
see any four players chest with Hikaru
well probably yeah
probably on his channel he he does that
pretty much all the time it's very
popular
I don't know III like to keep it clean I
like to keep my channel you know only
only two player chess friendly but we
might for those of you who are only
joining the chat and are asking who who
Tina is it says in the title of the
video as you can see tomorrow Friday
Arena with Valentina and sister it's
very very very clear what are your
qualifications or qualifications for
what I don't know I don't know I didn't
get who he was referring to all right so
he has 9 seconds he's still up a piece
but oh wow this is this could get ugly 7
seconds with C he has two extra oh and
he just blundered a road yeah
stuffed peppers really yeah blasphemy no
way yeah but do you actually eat eat the
peppers yes okay because a lot of people
say they prefer that but they never eat
them I don't eat paprika cabbage in
Sarma okay we have to check out this
game this is going to be a wild one
Yellen is playing against the mystery
person who whose identity we shall not
reveal just yet Jelena and she's doing
very well on time she only spent 15
seconds and it was some sort of a I was
asked and
naveen but a Scandinavian declined very
nice we'll see we'll see what happens
what do you watch or play I don't play
sports no yeah me neither
it's just not this is the only thing we
have in common yeah yeah yeah but no one
in our family watches sports life I
think I think we actually know more than
our dad even though we don't really
watch anything yeah do you know what
what's your day job I work at a
university I'm a research assistant and
pursuing PhD diploma how is the pursuit
going great should be feel be about done
quite quickly yeah yeah all right very
nice yeah so at least at least one of us
was I was able to do that
I tried college it didn't didn't go well
yeah I did the smarter things to do yeah
but yeah I mean I always say I tried
three colleges and I you know picked up
something from each of them and it was
it was enough to to gain some sort of an
amount of vast knowledge even though
even though I didn't finish any of them
unfortunately of course HD in which
subject our graphic technology tell them
tell them about the the the pool no it's
uh it's a really supreme technology
technology is it a secret
[Laughter]
son asks oh that's that's a weird thing
to say good thing the chat is going fast
what's the sisters name it's in the
title of the video or maybe you guys can
see the title maybe I'm just repeating
that for no reason it's Tina yeah yeah
it's basically the same valentina Tina
and I'm Antonio but also short Tony and
I am younger you know what should
Antonio change in his living room living
room nothing he should just move it to a
new house yeah yeah we we are planning
to do that Oh a Jelena is so much better
on time what is what is nada I'm doing
he has like one second short Tony seems
like a mafia name yeah it does but
everyone everyone you know connects Tony
with a mafia name because of The
Sopranos yeah and Jelena takes down
mothering very nicely done
very nice are you a Trekkie like a good
matter
[Music]
no I can't say that I am a what a
Trekkie aha
I I wouldn't say I'm a Trekkie
I mean I do enjoy it but I it's not like
I know like everything about it I just
think it's a good idea are you guys part
Italian no no no nothing to do with with
Italy who drink positive hoodie how are
you doing man do you know do you watch
our cats videos sometimes no you don't
know all right how that how does every
one of my videos start hello okay that's
that was an easy question I will think
of a tougher one Tina Tina is not active
in in playing chess but she really
really wants to learn but she's very low
on time so maybe maybe after the PhD
then we will have some time for chess
someone says have my smoking habits
annoyed you before yeah
everyone everyone was a smoker back then
we started smoking first you or me you
probably yeah I would say me after all
you're older yeah but only by by little
do you watch dark Deena dark no on
Netflix no I haven't seen it no not yet
okay well it's German its German but no
IIIi don't like that they put English
over it no they yeah they put English
over it so maybe you can also listen in
the original
German but I don't know it just looks
weird when you do it like that
synchronized English yeah but it it does
I don't know the the movement of the
mouth seems seems very weird it's Danish
actually not German really I always
thought it was German really Danish oh I
think the english dubbed its english
dubbed and someone again says that it's
German okay so it's we it's a tie
between Danish and German yeah what's
the story behind the smiley pillow that
there's no story they were just selling
smiley pillows in this store where we
sometimes go and you know I mean who
wouldn't get one yeah someone else is
saying it's Swedish I think we are being
trolled by the chat so I don't think
it's like a big mystery okay this is
like going too fast
who is which there are Tina already
entered that that between Carlson and
Caspar that Fisher is the best
all right so evil drunk takes takes a
point from the marula Demerol a I guess
it's damn early and we go deeper into
the oh here's a bent Feingold was right
but that game is pretty much over
so let's try to find one that is just
starting out okay this one's also
somewhere in the middle silver all
seemed at least yeah but it's not I like
to see a game from the start
diaspora from Alden from Albania okay we
have to go deeper yeah I think this will
do and I am not familiar with the names
Hasan Ali versus Magnus 16 Carlsen
alright and we have some d4
six III b6 action on the board no I
don't know if they were referring to us
actually as it is a weird thing to ask
okay that's two too quickly have you
answered which subject are you doing the
PhD with and we're gonna save the poop
up we don't want to reveal too much all
at once
well a lot of stuff but officially a
graphic designer
which of course you can tell from the
fact that my channel is so well designed
yeah you started together actually at
the same College yeah yeah you started
before me then I I joined and then I
didn't it I didn't like it yeah yeah
this is actually quite often well not
often but once a year they still invite
me to play some chests like for their
team because I was once a part of the
college and then I have like like a
right to help them out with with their
chests competitions and stuff oh you
have to speak louder yeah okay
where's the tournament unleashes yeah
I'm gonna have to put this like instead
of this guest camera spot I'm gonna have
to write link to the tournament in the
description below
someone is saying bro
is she single Tina are you single
she is not single far from this is the
title is the thumbnail related to the
new manga sort of yes and no and maybe
but we are going to talk about that
maybe in a week a bit more because the
the manga is coming do you speak
Croatian Serbian and Bosnian yes all
three yeah well we we understand it yeah
yeah there's it's the same language if
anyone asks you alright Tico's let's see
vogue vogue Z Gujarat's alright here we
have from Truman Harper from United
States versus Akshay comfy
[Music]
why yeah that is true
why are people telling me to say
drumsticks is that like something that
only sounds funny when you say it
drumsticks I I I'm pretty sure it's some
sort of a weird word that everyone's
making fun of and now they they want me
to say it I just don't think I could
think of anything funny involving
drumsticks Christopher Lewis nothing
long piece right Jelena is Antonio
single
I don't think so that's that's a weird
thing to ask I haven't been single for
for like a decade Y star Y star so
fascinating with his moves he that's
just how he was born I guess I mean
there's no way around it
AJ Agosto thanks for the contribution
man and if they actually help your game
that makes it old all the better
yeah we're not gonna say funny funny
words like this like what's with that
man yeah but try try sink Regency it's
where we live it's like well it's I
think you might struggle if you're like
from the states but if you're you know
somewhere from from these parts it's not
that big of a deal Vaughn Tina who is
the best-looking chess player how many
do you know more or less than five yeah
of course it's more give Tina a Morphy
head okay but first she has to play a
game and an impressive one at that
we don't just you know hand out more
feeds where did you get that shirt
Antonio oh oh yeah okay you can try and
guess if you if you can guess I don't
know how much you can see but pretty
good shirt right yeah
yeah try try and guess where I got that
yeah it's it's a mystery yeah it's
unsolvable like I don't think anyone
could solve that it's like the like a
true study a chess study all right and
you would you tricked loses on time the
cultured geek very nice very nice rings
ring no not really
which is weird I love everything about
such such a movie I mean I love fantasy
I love everything that has even that's
even remotely connected to fantasy and
for some reason I don't enjoy Lord of
the Rings maybe I should give it another
chance but it's like so long it's it
like takes forever I will maybe try and
watch it again but I don't know and it's
like it's not like I've seen it as soon
as it came out and I still didn't like
it it's like really weird it's it's it's
a mystery I thanks for the contribution
man yeah I have considered streaming on
Twitch and I actually do stream on
Twitch but not chess like early in the
mornings I will stream some old classics
like like Zelda from 1987 which I'm
doing for the previous four days and
we're having a lot of fun actually I I
suck at it badly but I am trying I'm
improving
how about Harry Potter is well I
wouldn't say I like it but I like it
much more than I do Lord of the Rings
yeah well then you have to say Potter
yeah I I think I even read the first
book and I can I can confirm at least
what other people are saying that the
book
is much better
oh that's a wondered mate oh nice nice
we can see that once again in sort of
slow motion night captures and then I
can't move the Queen okay
Queen captures Angie - very nice yes I
do cook but only when I have to so not
not out of pure joy no bloom core all
right let's see what's happening here
seems like a wild one for a straight
from the start do you know have you seen
Breaking Bad yeah but I've only seen
like I think three three seasons first
three seasons I still have to because I
can't watch
better call Saul before checking out the
the entire I guess I guess I can't I
mean I also heard the overlap so I
haven't see it I don't have much time on
my hands but the only show I did see
from the beginning to the end the only
one yeah like we haven't seen friends
every single one I saw around vidas
welcome to welcome to excellent
subscribers man good to have you on
board yes
what about Star Wars ok I like Star Wars
ok I like I like that's not worse but
not anymore
yeah ever since JJ Abrams took over it
just went downhill at least for me even
ESCO oh ok even s was also playing
that's göran göran sadder son
ah human yeah against the boogy boogy
watts how do you find two and a Half Men
ah like from one to five like two and a
half if there's really nothing else on
yeah do you know do you know the Beatles
yeah I someone asked me like which is my
favorite song
it's hard to pick one but I really like
the strawberry fields forever it's like
super weird it's like it's so weird that
it's really really really good oh yeah I
mean if you guys like matrix you will
you will really love the the manga when
it comes out you like Justin Bieber yeah
I I've never asked anyone in my entire
life do you like Justin Bieber and
they've said yes so how does where are
all of his fans I think they're much
younger than us yeah but they can't be
much younger forever maybe if you ask
even or Philip I don't even think they
know who he is you think so yeah okay
Ronaldinho a Stephen and Philip do they
know who Justin Bieber is and tell us in
the chat I am pretty sure he's listening
all right
even ESCO loses the boo Java's ah you
were so close even ESCO it's a shame but
you you can't win them all
Travie all right here seems like an
interesting one Rhenish versus Shahid
trial 3 you know do you play any video
games no no not not not even one the
only game you've ever played this like
Mortal Kombat yes yeah but like Mortal
Kombat 2 from Super Nintendo yeah I
didn't see if I didn't see if Ronaldinho
answered our question but do do we do
even in Filipino who Justin Bieber is I
think it's I think it's a valid question
[Laughter]
now what about the Big Bang Theory it
was a it was a good thing but now it's
just never never ending yeah I know but
it just it just became too stale I mean
I think it's good for fun nothing
serious but it's okay yeah
like the first three seasons are our art
which one of you got in trouble oh I
think it's uh it would be very close
yeah to decide that we both had our
moments how do you participate just
click on the link in the description
below it says Friday arena and you click
on it and that's just it and also after
this stream ends we will be publishing
the best moments of agamotto episode 2
by oh god muttering yo so do check that
out as well I will put a link to it in
the description below but not just yet
like like maybe a few seconds before
before the stream finishes yes I am
excellences subscriber even-even ESCO
says yes we know who is Justin Bieber
told you I don't know I don't know if
he's like still around or what does that
matter means it's a it's a super secret
super secret Deena why are you wearing a
bathrobe oh yes yeah I'd actually I
could I could maybe record the videos in
a bathroom that might not be actually
have a nice bathrobe like it'd be so
much more comfortable and but yeah we'd
have to really be careful not to you
know not to get any nasty discoveries
Ben Kukai thanks a lot man I I
appreciated that you you consider it
vast knowledge it's a samurai robe yeah
it's not a bathrobe ah I should I should
wear a bathrobe and the crown yes I can
totally see that happening
all right so your head is off a full
rook and even though it's five to five
seconds I think he can just easily win
this let's check and mate all right for
the next for the next three yeah they
can but it's it's a 15-second delay on
the stream stream no nice to Discovery's
all right dams dance how are you doing
that game is going on already let's look
for game this is just beginning
no no no culture deep we've already seen
a game by culture geek Astro chess dark
bull dark bull seems like he this is you
know heating up
Sahil thanks for the contribution man we
will we will ah yeah everywhere every
stream they asked me have you seen money
heist and I'm like no I haven't no I
haven't but guess what I have now
and it's actually excellent it's it's
really excellent and I was I was
actually very sad that you know I
finished season three and I'm like next
and there is no next so it's very it's
not very often that I get sad when when
you know something like this ends and I
have to wait for it but I was also sad
about the blacklist
like we also really started enjoying
blacklist and then it just stopped but
they they they mmm ok they finished the
job pretty creatively as they animated
the the rest of the show like they they
I think they fit four episodes into one
animated episode because they couldn't
record due to the you know situation in
the world I don't think so no it still
should be one more really are you a
mother yes I am season 4 is available Oh
someone is someone says that season 4 of
money heist is available The Witcher yes
ah finally somewhere The Witcher is
awesome
why do you like the show yeah look at
this Knight of 6 check pics of the Queen
oh very nicely done by dark bull I don't
think they're Italian names yeah Coyle
alright we have oil from chile crazy owl
play already playing Johnny
something happening Mita maratona who is
Meeta Marathon odds against Johnny 26
okay let's let's see that one yeah we
will watch dark but we just still
haven't figured out is it German Danish
or Swedish do you know do you think jess
is a sport yeah I mean it says so right
in the book of sports yeah yeah well I
know darkus German I said dark is German
and then people were like no it's
Swedish no it's yeah yeah
next in line for the podcast is still
still not to be named but like you guys
are still welcome to try and guess who
the next guest is for the podcast yeah
but no one got it so far at least I
haven't seen if anyone got it yeah a
five was interesting it's it's
definitely the way to go
coronal Dino Weiss chronal in your doing
the question marks what's what's with
the question marks coronal Deena it's
pretty weird Pedro el arte thank you for
the contribution man
who is the favorite between you guys
that's that's also a weird thing to say
Charlie for the podcast yeah I would
definitely enjoy having a podcast with
Charlie and especially especially about
chess with Charlie can I show you my
mortal game I could and I will maybe
yeah okay maybe after this maybe after
this tournament ends we we can do the
organ mat or immortal I've never never
shown it but it is it is truly amazing
all right I'm seeing you guys I'm seeing
you guys trying to guess but no I do not
know Rishi personally I only met him
once in Croatia last year when they were
in the inn in Zagreb for the
Grantchester nota Mortimer is not the
guest but I I do hope he he does attend
at some point all right well I can I can
say that someone guest but I'm not gonna
say who I didn't see yeah but I was
waiting for a lot of people to you know
guess so it's impossible to to point it
out yeah Tim Horton ropey well said
Hagen Medina no it's not Geary it's not
Geary
but of course it we are hoping to get to
get Geary in at some point all right
okay no no but those are those are very
good guesses all very good guesses maybe
someday
huh maybe someday yeah I mean I do hope
to get all of those people you guys you
guys mentioned but the way we we have to
take it slowly someone donated and said
hi I love your work and your sister is
really pretty thank you for the
contribution have I watched resurrection
earth to earth air to group air to grow
no nobody sounds sounds really epic the
way to open this
leeches arena is by clicking on the link
in the description below
no it is not Putin but that would be
awesome yeah you know do you watch anime
like on purpose or I've seen one episode
of Ozark and I I think I thought it was
like pretty good but I don't know why I
didn't continue
yeah I I still will say that more than
one of you have guessed who the next
guest is RBG Gor Singh oh let's see
Jelena doing well as usual good stuff
good stuff
okay 30 more minutes until the end of
the tournament so let's check up on our
leaders the modest guy is leading who
had a perfect streak and then lost the
game to Eric Nam who is also 14 here
without a lost game so let's see if he's
playing he seems to be a beast but he
got only a draw yeah all right let's see
it lets see it I think the only one so
far without loss in the top 10 I could
be wrong what could be this could be a
very good one playing against the top
seed Tigran Kazarian from Armenia white
chess not in Olympics it will be give it
give it time
no it's not Luka Modric no I think it'd
actually be an excellent guest and you
know we'd only talk about chess it'd be
great about chess and you know maybe
some a little bit of football I could
ask him a lot of nice questions about
football sensei I know like almost
nothing about football
no stranger things yes yeah I've seen
season 1 but then everyone was like
super hyped for season 2 but then season
2 came and I was just like yeah whatever
I saw everything
yeah are the Sun tea watch that no but
how is that weirder than then Harry
Potter because stranger things is like
filmed nightmare yeah but there aren't
any
is there like but there's no blood
there's no there is okay it's really
okay and Harry Potter is no it's pretty
much innocent okay there is that and
stuff but still okay I guess thus Hikaru
pronounced Ivan Madar correctly no he
doesn't
very very very few streamers actually
pronounce it correctly I I think he
pronounces it like a gamete or I think
something like that when it's in fact a
God motto without any any weird stuff
going on but I've I've heard much worse
am I playing planning a GM title in the
future not in the near future am i
following the comedians on board on
Samus Channel what are they having like
a tournament or something semifinals of
what no I don't know as part of
personally I have met him once in 2016
he was here in creation Capri minutes he
held a simultaneous exhibition we were
able to visit and and got a nice photo
with him all of us he'll and I got a
nice photo with him as did I and as did
yours out of and that's pretty much the
only time I've met him yeah the movie
probably terrible just terrible nothing
about that movie is good I've seen it a
few days ago actually
yeah and I'm one of the few people that
actually like Tobey Maguire and no
regardless like I actually do do like
the guy as an actor and I still didn't
enjoy the movie but I didn't enjoy it
because they they portrayed everything
so poorly it was that's not the way it
went down
you can watch the game against Kasparov
who can watch the game against Kasparov
people can yeah but Goren's Colonel
Dino's entire family pretty much played
against Kasparov the TV show Lost I
think I've never seen it I've seen it
and but I've never seen like all the
episodes and I always wanted to but I
think I think that I the director or
someone or I'm not the director but the
writer of the show said that they're
actually like is no ending to the show
that he just didn't find a nice ending
and then he left it like completely
vague Filipina playing against
whorehouse alright we're gonna we're
gonna check that out in the next one why
is he giving up the roof that's weird
is there a mate God there is mate Wow
Rock after screen here yeah that was
nice so that was good that was good
well spotted and is there mate now no
there isn't
I thought maybe captures and then Queen
f2 but King can capture on h3 okay
fifteen seconds they it's for them to
brawl it out we're just here to enjoy
the show
yes who tricked that is a funny word
Susak is sometimes set for a dog in
Croatia yeah you cannot capture
sculptures because of characters
how is your American accent I I would
say I I don't have I don't have a good
any accent let alone American I was
hoping to one day do a good pirate but
it's not not going well
why do I always say sorry about that
Tina do you know yes that is C you know
you know Stephanie Sam I had a
tournament he lost final who was in the
tournament
yeah the flagging is real but you know
in such top-tier games flagging it
always happens all right so is Hawk
house still playing Filipino and where
are they were where were they not in the
top ten no they're not playing it
anymore do you know all right Cindy hell
do you know why what I'm most scared of
really what seaweed still well I don't
know if I'd be like super scared of it
but I wouldn't want to stand in it yeah
yeah I mean yeah that is what I mean all
right modest guy we still haven't seen
by the modest giver we are waiting for
okay but let's check out a few more
games from from the other side all right
Hawke house we haven't seen Hawke house
but he is in the middle of something but
it seems to be in the middle of
something very nice you know who whole
house is No Slavko yes against Brutus
next podcast is with the sister no maybe
well maybe not not the absolute next one
but maybe one in the future oh that is
that is very well said a pirate cannot
be afraid of seaweed hmm a meter high I
mean I'm either gonna have to muscle I'm
either gonna have to beat my fear of
seaweed or abandon my dream of becoming
a pirate it's not a not an easy one and
Hawke house takes down Brutus good job
good job Slavko all right let's see Nico
is Nico playing yeah but Rafael Raj is
ruffling Filipina okay we've already
seen Filipino Messiah naka Rodin all
right knock Rodin let's let's do this
okay Tina which is your favourite piece
what
literature like yeah alright we're gonna
check out the yellowness game but only
if we have permission maybe next one
peace of mind yeah I got my three nurses
as well peace of mind
that means Sun tea piece of cake ah
someone wrote 24th february how do they
know 24th february no maybe they added
you somewhere i don't know but it is it
is weird
yeah how is your sister so gorgeous it
kind of runs in the family
I mean boxing sheep no I've stopped
smoking 200 some years ago two years ago
and three months something like that
it was around Easter of 20 20 18 L
Spiros says my birthday is the 22nd of
February and we are February sisters
there you go alright knock her out then
I remember we've seen one game by naca
Rodin cuz I remember it but I do not
remember
I am Sidman have you been to Canada not
yet not yet alright alright Nikora 32
sahi berserk that's why he's a long time
Tina seems to be a little bit
uncomfortable
yes she's out of beer that that must be
it
all right you you alright let me just
check this you you tend to the chat I
will get you a refill okay dad that'll
work best opening to the feet for magnus
carlsen that's I don't think I don't
think that feet is opening related can
you get a hello everyone from Tina yes
but only only after she returns yeah its
wine glasses and beer cuz I'm having
wine I thought yeah I mean I do like
beer but I thought today wasn't I wasn't
feeling it to be like a beer day aha you
still need to watch my game against
Hikaru well it I can tell you one thing
it was very intense for the first 15
moves like could have gone either way
and then well then something happened
when are we coming to London well not
not at the moment no can I play the
guitar and stream ah YouTube will
YouTube will take it down for for
copyright infringement you know every
song is for cords anything idea - I'll
hit one song and it was in this position
that it went hit car was way well well
said Spiro maybe spoiling it a bit too
much for everyone but okay I mean I'm
not saying it's not it's not true yes I
I have I've been to Netherlands but long
long ago Pumbaa you may become a mod but
I don't think we need more mods at the
moment or I don't know if my mods tell
me differently I will I will consider it
is there a difference between chess calm
and leeches rating calculation did
accuracy I wouldn't say so I think it's
I think it's perfectly the same did I
smoke weed in Netherlands I was six when
I went so I'm gonna go home but we don't
know why is the guest cam blank well it
only on blanks when a guest appears and
well here we have a guest in in real
life so we don't need to use a guest cam
and I was too lazy to to fix the
interface yeah I got a van a Torino
nailed it
coffee shop six-year-old confirmed
uh-huh the leaches rating is slightly
higher than the chest com1 I haven't
played as much on chess calm but I did
play some blitz games not so long ago
and she's got calm and I didn't feel
like there was a difference all that
much rating wise even felt I could get a
bit higher on chair calm Deena they said
you you should they want to hear you say
hello everyone when you return oh hello
everyone but like like more more
powerful hello everyone oh can you play
the guitar
no all right yeah piano a little bit I
don't have a piano I'm sorry I will I
will prepare a piano for the next stream
I didn't say I don't like Sodom ah no
you do you know how many people you've
offended there
[Music]
favorite metal band do you have a
favorite metal band no well I'm gonna go
with system of adawn if that is
considered metal it was it was my
favorite band growing up like when I was
very young I I don't think it counts as
metal but yeah I didn't know that smell
yeah but I don't know if it is metal if
it is actually considered metal alright
yeah I was like like the biggest fan
like it was the only thing that mattered
every day yeah I didn't listen to them
but I know every song yeah yeah I might
even I might even fire up some some
system of a dawn today just you know get
in the mood that that ended long ago why
is there always tall in the in the video
well he's cuz he's the man
do you know Misha Tina this gentleman
here Misha yeah yeah me I'll tell yes
yes Kevin
Sean Jota says big destroyer is best big
destroyer is best thank you for the
contribution I imagine big destroyer is
a metal band
no I don't I don't watch cricket
I know it's popular very much amongst a
lot of people but i-i've never seen a
game of cricket like if you guys if you
guys tell me that I should watch at
least one game of cricket
I will artena here's the one up your
alley Jon Snow or Khal Drogo makes no
sense
oh you don't want to be with someone who
has prettier than you yes yeah I imagine
a pig destroyer is is a metal band since
we were discussing that and I will be
streaming zelda again most likely
tomorrow but I'll see I have many games
the cover from today's tournament open
tournament in Parchin in Serbia I've
never heard of it but I do visit Serbia
at least once a year so I would be I
would be happy to attend if if it takes
place yeah I mean that's like both I
mean both no yeah but if you include
season 8 then any show other than Game
of Thrones
[Music]
did I play fiscal 2020 I I have no idea
what that is
Shangri no that's already over newpsie
no nope see nopsi Akuma Hamdi mohammadi
thanks for the contribution man when are
the Dragons coming it at the end of
season 1
yes bureau season 8 was he didn't just
ruin the show it it went like like every
show we watch after that because you
like watch the other show and you're
like yeah it's it's okay but it's not
Game of Thrones oh yeah
that the adventure sucks so I don't know
and it III heard their they're already
doing spin-offs at least that okay I
don't know if they're doing it now do
this situation and world about that they
already started recording one of them
and I don't know how how old that will
turn out have you been to Brazil no no I
haven't yeah Kyle Kyle Kaiser says
season 8 ruined my life there you go
yeah almost yeah this is yeah this is
actually a game each time usually a beer
man but I'm trying to mix it up lately
Deena do you know do you know Marin
Cilic
Martin Jewish yes of course yeah I think
everyone in Croatia does even not
non-sport people like us why does my
score look like a binary code well you
you know you win some you lose some
that's a good question what other sports
do you follow other than chess I think
that's for me like no no other sports
like actively no like sometimes I check
like the sports news but like only only
the major news but that's pretty much it
yes yes she's fifteen at the moment and
she really shouldn't be drinking beer on
stream through detective no yes it's
Woody Harrelson and Matthew McConaughey
it can't be bad but only the first
season I thought was okay but still
didn't like the ending like I like the
show I didn't like the ending and then
season 2 which is with Colin Ferrell and
yeah it was no I would the describe it
as you know kind of kind of watchable no
no no no like two and a Half Men you can
like always watch that and it will
always be watchable like the little kid
he's so good I don't remember his name
but he's the jaar jaar little kids name
yeah like the the the moocher is Alan
and the little kid is come on help me
out guys
like the hmm Jack Jack no Jayde yeah
yeah Jake yeah yeah thanks he's a he's a
legend he's such a legend all right
that's uh what's happening here
ma boo Jada vs. Navi told Navy Navy at
love yep a lot of a lot of things
happening but nothing okay that's
something so seven more minutes we're
gonna check out this game and then we're
gonna check up on the leaders
how about Vikings have you seen Vikings
no I've seen the first three seasons and
I started off good but then you just
know they don't enjoy it anymore
favorite Star Wars movie do you have I
don't have a favorite a favorite Star
Wars movie I imagined the well either
either the fourth one or the fifth one
or you know chronologically the first or
second but it's hard to hard to decide
favorite chess player under 35 well you
really narrowed it down I mean like
they're all all of them are under 35
pretty much I don't follow sports yeah
only only the market favorite Avenger
very topic yeah oh that's a that's a
tough one
yeah hmm Wow favorite Avenger hmm how is
pretty cool yeah but I don't know but
it's they they made it so much about
Iron Man that it's hard not to pick him
like he literally beat stano's so I know
I would I would probably go with Iron
Man Marvel movies suck yeah they do but
you know what are you gonna do I like
kid most of the mall is he's not an
Avenger
yeah but he's like the cool yeah yeah I
know spoilers yeah sorry
no spoilers okay yeah but there's like
you know there's hashtag don't spoil the
end game and I just spoiled it even more
like even I don't think it was even
either April or June but bring Harrison
Ford on the podcast yeah I think they
almost went bankrupt by getting him in
the new Star Wars movie just for that
you know a few scenes and I don't think
he'd be he'd be easy to get I heard like
he was the only he was the only actor
who was paid an eight-figure number for
the part in that movie I'm Kitty adavi
thank you for the contribution man
thanks from India Disney going bankrupt
uh-huh yeah I don't think so that's a
figure figure speech speech save a
favorite planet I'm gonna go with earth
yeah it's pretty it's a pretty good
planet yeah woody woody harrelson might
may come for free yeah if he visited
maybe yeah am I the only one in the
family who plays chess pretty sure yeah
yeah yeah my grandfather of course he
was a freedom master he played my uncle
place but not actively and my both of
our parents actually do know how to play
but you know they just don't know they
play better really yeah
why don't I like increment because I'm a
big fan of manager time like if you if
you haven't managed your time and your
position just crumbles that's I mean and
the positions that arise in a no
increment chest are much much better
than the positions that arise in games
with increment why didn't i cover the
latest DCC games well there's kind of
this big tournament going on and now
here we have the finals between crossing
and Geary but when that finishes I will
tend to the to the T CEC all right
leader of the tournament modest guy is
playing so let's check this out and both
of them Burger King Spiro
miss Spiro thank you for the
contribution volunteen ah what is
something you learned about your brother
only through his chest stream haha she's
trolling you hard really okay there but
they are they're only saying nice things
about me now because you're here like if
you weren't here there'd be like whoa
get out here uh uh here's a good one
cats or dogs I really like all animals I
think my brother can also yeah sometimes
even even too much yeah I had to get one
of those for the house it would probably
be dog yeah buddy my head well yeah but
if you get a dog you can also get like a
cat
like we don't cuz there's like no room
here even though mayor really likes cats
but but yeah it really could be
Aleksei thanks for the contribution man
yes we've will cleared 700k on under 800
Tina's arena or Matt abolish
neither did you say neither four neither
okay what a question
yeah no I'm not vegan but you are like
to be bad you're haunted by becoming one
yes
oh that's a nice capture Wow Charis
Charis check and how do you win this you
character yeah now it's kind of clear
wow yeah beautiful beautiful stuff and
now he wins yeah very nice we're gonna
watch this game until the end to enjoy
the technique and he blunders the rook
now I guess he's hoping for a stalemate
yeah he's gonna play it out to stalemate
easier are your sister Swedish are your
sister Swedish Swedish no no is the
Netflix show dark Swedish most
subscribers from which country still
from United States it's around the
United States like 30 percent oh and
we've reached the end of the tournament
it's 9:30 sharp and we have the lineup
we're gonna wait for a few more seconds
for the entire tournament to finish and
for all the games to end and then we are
going to announce the winners
yes you sister are Swedish do not tell
allies yes well said well said I am a
Serena alright so now I will add
something to the description of this
video
I will write something and then the link
will appear it is the link to our
materials new episode of the Argan
matter best moments which we will now
introduce after we announce the winners
of the tournament Tina do you want to do
want to have the honors yes of course do
we start well first you announce the top
three with kind of a powerful voice then
you go to the four five six seven eight
with a slightly less powerful voice and
that's it okay the first one in the
winner right mhm
is the modest guy very nicely done
very nice the second one is Tigran gasa
Kazarian mm-hmm very nice to Graham and
the third one is yourself
Bravo Yas oh that's yelling us brother
if any of you are still mysterious with
that one okay next one in the line is
Travis numata the fifth one is Eric Nam
mm-hmm sixth one is incredible yeah one
two three
seventh Knockhill alright eight wanted
101 that's true and nine is where we
love the we will all die yeah I did not
see that I thought you'd be like oh yeah
and the tenth one is shut up yeah shut
up well done everyone
alright so good game everyone we're
going to announce the winner Cinda in
the next video yours are of also
congratulate everyone there you have it
he says great tournament congratulations
youse are once again one more names
and/or
one more name you okay you can pronounce
one more name pick whichever one but
yeah he's always in the tournament good
job of Arad so yeah and now we are going
to publish while this is live
the Akkad matters best moments Episode
two by none other than a Ghana Torino so
here it is we are publishing it now and
with this publication we are ending the
stream so published and yes best moments
episode two has been published enjoy
guys and SIA SIA in the next one
Tina thank you for joining me thank you
for and yeah we're gonna have some more
more beer wine and enjoy the rest of the
evening
see you soon guys